what are you working on right now
obviously tour is very popping um what
what I know you got the hot commodity
ship going down yes High commodity
mixtape just dropped go tune in got some
good people on there but I'm you know
hopefully I'm working on like maybe
possibly a deluxe you know who's on the
original right now I have ta ass shy bin
laddin and Ma shout out to Ty shout out
to Tai did you get this like hang with
him nah no I met him real quick I just I
seen them like on on chance at a apple
music event and I was like yo let's see
if I can get him to answer the phone
right now on FaceTime okay let's see he
might be with Kanye West doing a seance
for the new album he probably won't even
know who I
am imagine he goes he's like who is this
I have to explain to him he's on my song
hey you know you're on her album well I
think when you're like the hook God like
Tai's one of those guys who's like the
go-to Hook
guy who else is one it like blast is
getting there who else a a Boogie's a
hook guy a boogie definitely a hook guy
I feel like a boogie is he's not g to
answer it's a busy man he's I mean he is
dropping a joint album with Kanye proba
let me see if I can get mared to answer
the
phone Mary J blig yeah Jesus do you know
Mary jij yes Mary is my bestie really
mhm that's pretty I felt like cuz when
you said that like oh let me see if I
could get TI and I felt like you was
trying to like upstage me a little bit
nah get married on the
phone I want to just tell her she's
amazing nah I ain't going to call Mary
the thing about Mary J blig is like you
know I kind of really I went and saw her
in Brooklyn
in what when was I in New York
last year ear she she had the tour in
New York I was about to say she was on
tour that [__] was amazing she's amazing
and she brought out everybody in she is
amazing everybody shows up for Mary she
had Jada on there uh Fab uh [__]
Diddy came out that [__] was crazy she
be having everybody outside she didn't
do a versus either which I think would
have been like who do a versus with me I
would like to have just seen her put
someone to shame you know what I'm
saying I was about to say who the [__]
going to do that with Mary there was
like I feel like all the cuz you know
who else I wanted to see do a versus cuz
I just wanted to see him destroy whoever
they put him against would have been
Buster
Rhymes Buster would have [__] caught
a bust ain't doing versus no cuz
everybody's
scared he did not do one because
everybody was scared to get that work
work Buster rymes
live yeah I seen him um live I went to
go see 50 Cent oh me too phenomenal 50
people aren't famous no more did you go
to New York I no I went to like Jersey
yeah I went to Jersey how was it to see
did he bring anybody out nobody is
famous no more like it was like so like
mindblowing like 20 20 25 years later
you got people grown ass men coming to
from far away wearing [__] wife
beaters and bulletproof vest like white
men yeah dressed like 50 Cent that [__]
was it was inherently they weren't in
black face where
God I got to ask imagine that' be
terrible that would be terrible it was
like it was so amazing like it was just
the coolest [__] ever like I always say
like the goats mhm like and you know
Buster was on with him so like just
watching them perform like even at the
BET Awards watching LL Cool J BT Awards
this year everybody like no backtrack
they running up and down 40 years old
and they're not yeah yeah that's the one
thing these young kidss are L like this
whole generation raps over their [__]
vocals and like you see 50 that tour was
I told everybody Cyrus you came to that
tour right no TK came that [__] was
crazy yeah it was like beautiful the
production the and when all the tours
were getting canceled 50 was selling out
everywhere I was like man look
broomal like it was just so amazing I
was like that's so crazy I hope in 25
years I tweeted that that was probably I
think it was my I I tweeted it out but
it's probably my favorite concert I've
been to In Like A decade damn that was
just crazy wow I was just like 50 doing
all the hits like damn like we where
this [__] where's this [__] at anymore
you know what I'm saying that [__] was
crazy bust was really cool to oh yeah
like when he did the thing where uh
split star was like turning him up and
he started rapping low and he yes and he
he was doing the DJ thing that [__] was
crazy so if you just started rapping
what was the what like changed your life
as a rapper what was what was it song so
it just you that song went crazy and
then you're and then all of a sudden
you're just in it your first song ever
recorded no not ever record ever ever
released yeah like my first this is my
song boom and was there something that
like you guys did was it Tik Tok was it
what was the Catalyst of that I just I
posted it everywhere I posted it on Tik
Tok Instagram and Twitter all did a
million views Jes in a day Jes wow just
a snippet yo man congratulations thank
you so much that's a big deal yes it is
cuz a lot of people man they you know
they got to everyone's path is different
in hip-hop so it's dope to see and
you're really you're a highle rapper
he's the one who sent me your [__] and
was like yo we got to get her on she's
hard I love that shout out to you boie
thank you um what's what you
seey the in my one it was the one I
showed you yeah you like that period so
the mixtape is out people can support it
Deluxe on the way hopefully hopefully
I'm I'm still stuck on if I want to do a
deluxe I feel like the deluxe thing was
like happening for a while but I've
noticed like it's the artist stopped
doing it you know what I would do a
deluxe form to get cuz a lot of the
songs on hot commodity are like fairly
old okay like the [__] that I was doing
like immediately after I dropped tofe um
but I got so much music so much music
and I think I want to like kick out the
rest that's like mixtape era you know
what I'm saying like this is me just I
want to rap rap you know well you know
what you could do is just put a new
project out and then it'll yeah but if I
do a new project it's going to be new
polished you know what I'm saying super
refined May versus like I'm coming up
I'm hungry I want to show you who I am
before you know what I'm saying I start
punching [__] in their face you know
not literally of course maybe
figuratively punch these [__] in
their face right figuratively and
sonically literally don't do it cuz then
you'll be in jail these [__] is
outside snitching bro you're right it's
rough I feel like every time I open my
phone I just see somebody people just be
snitching on themselves now like the
dude who got arrested for shooting Tupac
this dude's been doing interviews
admitting to this for like five years oh
really I don't know what's what you
talking about so this so this guy in
vegas named Kefi D he got arrested uh by
Las Vegas Metro Police for his
involvement in Tupac's murder now the
thing is is he's been doing interview
views for like he did Vlad he's done a
bunch of platforms I don't want to just
pin it on Vlad but he's been talking
about openly in like
describing the murder of Tupac and him
being there for like five years on
podcasts so it's it's like they came and
arrested him they came and they raided
his house they took bullets out of his
house and they put him in jail now he's
not convicted yet but this just happened
so it's like yeah what did you think was
going to [__] happen so he said like
like yeah shot to
he was he said he was in the passenger
seat of the car that killed
Tupac what his cousin is Orlando Brown
the dude who supposedly was the shooter
so it's like why would you admit that on
like there like what like wait what I'm
confused I thought the P wait huh it's
crazy yeah I'm confused so they arrested
him for being a passenger yeah because
he was involved in the hit and the other
dude's dead oh that was my next question
like why they you arrest him he's dead
so they proved that it was the other guy
yeah I mean I I
don't this guy admitted it I'm going to
go look up every I'm about to full down
a rabbit hole do it of that and then
I'mma text you like yo mhm I'mma find
out what's going on cuz that's
interesting well listen um hot commodity
go get the project you're on the road
all over the country with Flo Millie yes
yes so you can go support her live got
the merch popping yes but it's not out
yet you you're on tour you got to take
the merch on to listen I made some last
minute decisions you got to sell the
shirts to the fans you know who you got
to talk to about that I rap all right I
don't make t-shirts well all right the
merch is coming soon y appreciate you
pulling up thank you for having me boom